they drill into your head Fidelity
bravery and integrity from day one and
we see it on TV shows and everything
we're all led to believe that this
institution is beyond reproach and
it's not it's as simple as that it's not
above reproach uh they are sinful human
beings just like me just like every
other but then there is malice or hubris
or a goal to strive to promote and those
things aren't often aligned with the
Constitution with the oath we took it's
not aligned with how law enforcement is
supposed to properly function in this
nation and when you start seeing those
things uh it at first for me it was like
maybe that's just a personality Quirk of
that person or that supervisor but then
over time it's it it's repetitive maybe
different instances different things
that occur but
it it starts to build and then there's a
mountain of evidence where there's a lot
of wrongdoing going on